[Music]
today's question comes from regina in
kentucky regina writes my husband's 86
year old father moved in with us after
his wife passed away
at the time he had over two million
dollars in retirement investments two
years ago he met a woman who's 54. he
has spent well over 800 000 on her
nothing his children say will deter him
from pulling money out of his
investments to make her happy when we
talk to him about this he says if he
runs out of money we'll just have to
provide for him my husband and i did not
sacrifice to build our retirement just
to support a lovesick old man
what is the family obligation to support
aging family members can i just divorce
my father-in-law
you know what dave i've been doing this
a long time i've never heard that wow
can i divorce my father-in-law i love
sick old man
she is over this can you tell
dave what do you think about this
about her i think she's pissed i i know
she
is yeah yeah um
yeah it's pretty obvious to see the the
the the email has heat on it yeah i just
set it down it burns
um
this reminds me of an inverse problem
and i don't i don't have a ton of
experience with
um 86 you know 87 88 what we call
geriatric older folks
family members
i always i i know that there is a
i feel a responsibility if you will to
to love and support my parents as best i
can the other side of this is it reminds
me of an old henry cloud statement when
you're talking about young kids which is
if he's 15 and he was acting like this
henry would say dr clyde would say he
needs some problems
and the 86 year old who is taking
advantage of his children at this point
and just burning through his money which
he's allowed to do it's his money but he
also has no repercussion for it because
he feels like he's got a safety net so
at some point
it feels like the his kids can make a
make set their boundaries and then dad
with his
1.2 million dollars left gets to make
some of his own decisions
what do you think about that
that sounds fardy feels harsh just
saying that out loud too um no here's
the thing i
think that we're
called to take care of our family i
agree but we need to define
take care of our family right the
problem with enablers is is that they
and she's not
[Laughter]
but uh the problem with enablers is is
that they define help improperly
uh they provide help as being nice and
allowing people to continue in their mis
behavior that's not actually helping
this man correct this man has another
problem okay we everyone hearing this
story through this lady's eyes anyway uh
is really confirmed that this 54 year
old is not attracted to this 86 year old
she's attracted to his money right she's
a gold
he's well digger
his birthday suit needs earning okay i
mean this is this is not an attraction
this is a money thing it's a money play
and um so
you know he's being taken advantage of
are you helping him
by winking and nodding at it
that's enabling i don't think you're
helping him right so i think you got to
love him not be disgusted love him
enough to not be disgusted with him
she's pretty angry but gently and kindly
just say dad
are some consequences
of your misbehavior right
because this lady's not after you she's
taking advantage of you everyone that
loves you is telling you that
and you technically have a right to be
stupid that's not illegal it's your
money it's your money
but you can't live here yeah while
you're doing it we're not going to
condone it and you need to go ahead and
be on notice that we do not feel
obligated to take care of you
um as if you weren't didn't burn through
two million dollars
by giving it to a gold digger and so dad
um if you're going to continue to give
her money you can't stay here and you
cannot expect future help from us now if
you're hungry you can come over and have
dinner
we're not gonna allow you to be hungry
we're not gonna you know but we are not
obligated to support you
while you're doing cocaine right
i always just kind of one of the things
i do in my head if i think i'm being an
enabler because i really people think
i'm just a smart outlet which i am but
they they also you know but i got this
huge heart and i have a real tendency to
participate in people's insanity just
keep going and going i don't know i
think most people do most of us that
love people you know we have a tendency
to do that and i just extrapolate it to
something extreme
and say if he was doing cocaine would
you allow him to stay in your house no
well all that is is another form of
misbehavior
if he was you know if he was boiling
crack in the back bedroom
you know would you allow him to stay
here that's another form of misbehavior
but that's kind of taking it crazy but
that helps you think about
even though this this is a little more
socially acceptable
than boiling crack in the back bedroom
yeah right and so
um you do you do
you'll mess up my poetry but um but yeah
that's uh can i tell you some heat that
i think i feel on this yeah and this is
since regina's not here i think she's
been mad a long time she's been mad a
long time she's mad at her husband for
not stepping in the middle of this
and this is hard
but when you have an 86 year old in your
home with this kind of money it's easy
to start spinning it in your head it's
easy to start thinking man just when he
so-and-so passes away we'll be able to
get this and we'll be able to take care
of that and to see it just liquidating
on somebody who you think has ulterior
motives oh well we all do it just i
think i think i think
i mean i i just i don't think there's
any question about that but yeah yeah
you need to check your own heart and
make sure what you're really he's
allowed to do what he wants to do with
his money but he's not allowed to live
in my house but you've got to draw
boundaries yeah and i'm not required by
moral standards to take care of
someone's misbehavior i'm required to
honor my father and mother which means i
honor the office
of father i'm required to honor the
president
we've had several presidents in the last
few years that i agreed with almost
nothing any of them did right but that
doesn't mean i'm going to dishonor the
office of the of the president of the
united states i can i don't have to
dishonor the office of father
but i can dishonor his behavior there
you go i can disagree with the
president's behavior you can draw
boundaries and go that's out of control
you're acting like an alzheimer's
patient quit that you know i'm not gonna
take take direction from you
uh
and so and this is important y'all have
already talked to him you've done the
right thing you sat down and talked to
him he said i don't care
yeah she's more important than you all
are yeah so go go live with her go live
with her boundaries and see how long you
get to stay after you run out of money
not very long yeah about 20 seconds
oh man so that's so sad that is
heartbreaking but yeah you are gonna
have to move him out um and your
husband's going to be the one that does
it and your husband's going to stack up
step up and get a backbone and deal with
this because you're going to end up
really further pissed at him if you
don't yeah you're going to end up losing
your marriage over this you all got to
be on the same page right here yeah and
it feels like
you feel yeah i think while your
husband's gone up to about a three boil
you boiled over she's over
and
uh and you know
you're gonna end up thinking you can
deal with this and it's not it's not in
your
purview to deal with his dad no because
what happens is is his dad's going to go
away and pass away
and then you're going to have to lose
your husband because you kicked my dad
out yeah and um you're going to have a
whole other set of mess right yeah
there's got to be together there's a
different script that's going to play
then that's exactly right so everybody's
got to get on the same page